usually Macbeth is about two characters
wanting more and the greed that comes
with that I thought it'd be interesting
to flip it so Macbeth is a product of
war and that then plays into his
ambitions to become king and the first
day of rehearsals justins was like this
is a guy who's suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder and I was
like actually Shakespeare wrote about it
that's how ahead of his time he was if
you think about it people didn't even
know a post-traumatic stress disorder
was after World War Two and called it
shell shock you know what are these live
you horario that man-made questions he's
seeing things right at the beginning and
the get-go the witches are they really
there are these things that we see or
imagine you know we know this now from
mike soldiers coming back from Iraq
going down clapham high street next
thing it's Basra literally and they
think they're in a war zone and the
banquet scene Lady Macbeth says sit
worthy friends
pray you keep seat the fittest momentary
upon a thought he will again be well
don't worry you know he suffered from
these fits before we've all seen it
before it'll pass and so all of that
just crystallized it was massive help to
me I didn't as I never saw